WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THIS
EARLIER.
I SAW THIS THIS WEEKEND.
I HAD TO BRING UP.
THE COLORADO SUPREME COURT RULED
THAT BUSINESSES CAN FIRE
EMPLOYEES FOR THE USE OF MEDICAL
MARIJUANA.
OKAY.
EVEN IF IT'S OFF DUTY.
NOT TALKING ABOUT SMOKING IN THE
BATHROOM, RIGHT.
THE CASE IS A QUADRAPLEGIC WHO
WAS FIRED FROM DISH NETWORK
FOR FAILING A DRUG TEST
>> AS IF THINGS WERE NOT [BEEP]
BAD ENOUGH.
>> Larry: IS IT FARE TO FIRE
SOMEONE FOR WHAT THEY DO ON
THEIR OWN TIME.
>> IT DEPENDS ON THE JOB.
THIS GUY WAS CUSTOMER SERVICE.
IF YOU HAVE TO FLY A PLANE OR
WORK, DRIVE A BUS.
YA, DON'T -- BE IN SHAPE FOR
WORK.
I MEAN, YOU WORK AT STAPLES GET
HIGH.
[LAUGHING]
>> IT SUCKS.
SMOKE CRACK.
>> Larry: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
CRACK.
>> I THINK IT'S KIND OF UNFAIR.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IF HE WAS
DRINKING ALCOHOL THEY WOULDN'T
FIRE HIM.
IT'S LEGAL IN COLORADO.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
>> Larry: RIGHT.
>> I THINK IT'S BANG OUT OF
ORDER
Larry: BANG OUT OF ORDER
I LIKE THAT.
>> THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID.
Larry: DOES THIS SEEM LIKE A
VIOLATION OF RIGHTS,
LEWIS?
>> IT JUST SEEMS STUPID AS A LOT
OF THINGS WE DO.
SON OF A BITCH WE ALLOW PEOPLE
TO POP KLONOPIN  AND GO TO WORK.
COME ON.
>> Larry: SPEAKING OF [BEEP]
HERE IN AMERICA.
DONALD TRUMP IS RUNNING.
FIRST THOUGHTS.
>> MY FIRST THOUGHT.
Larry: YES.
>> IF SOMEONE WERE TO HOLD A
SWORD I'D RUN AT IT.
[LAUGHING]
>> Larry: WHAT IS THE OPINION
OVER SEAS WHEN THEY SEE SOMEONE
LIKE DONALD TRUMP RUN FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> DONALD, YOU'RE FIRED.
THAT'S THE OPINION.
DUDE, NO.
>> I DISAGREE.
I DON'T KNOW.
I LOVE HIM.
>> YOU'RE A TRUMP FAN.
>> HE WON MY VOTE TODAY.
HE CAME OUT TALKING LIKE FLOYD
MAYWEATHER.
IT WAS AMAZING.
>> Larry: READY FOR THE FIGHT.
>> I'M REALLY RICH.
FLOYD SAID THAT BEFORE HIS
FIGHT.
>> Larry: HE DID.
>> HE WAS TALKING LIKE A RAPPER.
I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO DROP A
MIXED TAPE.
[LAUGHING]
>> IT'S AMAZING.
Larry: THERE IS NO WAY TRUMP
CAN BACK ANYTHING HE SAID.
>> WHEN DID WE BEAT JAPAN?
AT ANYTHING?
>> SECOND WORLD WAR.
HELLO.
>> LITTLE LEAGUE WORLD SERIES.
YOU KNOW -- JUST -- JUST.
YOU KNOW WHAT REALLY THE PROBLEM
IS HERE, WE HAVE REACHED THE
POINT IN TIME THAT SATIRE AND
REALITY HAVE INTERSECTED.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
IT'S LIKE YOU SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SHOW.
HOW DO WE MAKE THIS [BEEP]
FUNNIER THAN IT IS.
>> Larry: IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS REPEAT IT
BACK THIS.
IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT IRAN.
>> I WILL STOP IRAN FROM GETTING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WE WON'T BE USING A MAN LIKE
SECRETARY KERRY WHO IS MAKING A
HORRIBLE AND LAUGHABLE DEAL.
THEN GO INTO A BICYCLE RACE AT
72 YEARS OLD AND FALLS AND
BREAKS HIS LEG.
I WON'T BE DOING THAT.
I PROMISE, I WON'T BE IN A
BICYCLE RACE.
>> WE DON'T WANT TO SEE HIM --
Larry: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
HE'S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE HIM IN
SPANDEX.
>> Larry: IT'S NOT EVEN MAKING
SENSE.
>> WHAT'S AMAZING IS HE DIDN'T
SMOKE.
>> WELL, HE PROBABLY DID.
>> I DOUBT IT.
>> ALL OF THOSE RICH OLD GUYS
ARE ON EVERYTHING.
>> REALLY.
>> COME ON.
>> THAT'S A SOBER THOUGHT.
>> OF COURSE IT'S A SOBER
THOUGHT.
LOOK AT HIS HAIR.
[LAUGHING]
>> Larry: ALL THE HAIR IS COMING
UP -- I THINK THE HAIR IS COMING
UP AND SLOWLY DRAINING THE
BLOOD.
>> THE SIGN FOR HIS CAMPAIGN IS
JUST HIS HAIR.
>> IT'S JUST WRONG.
Larry: CHINA.
>> HEY, I'M NOT SAYING THEY'RE
STUPID.
I LIKE CHINA. I SOLD AN
APARTMENT FOR $15 MILLION TO
SOMEBODY FROM CHINA.
AM I SUPPOSE TO DISLIKE THEM?
>> Larry: THEY'RE GOING TO
DISLIKE YOU NOW.
>> ALONG WITH THE REST OF
AMERICA.
>> THERE IS A TREMENDOUS START
TO A FOREIGN POLICY IDEA.
>> Larry: RIGHT.
>> YOU ALWAYS WANT TO START WHAT
YOU GOT PAID TO SELL AN
APARTMENT.
YOU KNOW LOGICAL STUFF.
>> OF COURSE.
>> LIKE EVERYTHING THERE.
arry: JUST MAKE IT MAKE
SENSE FIRST, PLEASE.
LEWIS.
>> THIS EXPLAINS EVERYTHING.
DONALD TRUMP IS STANDING ON
THE VERREZZANNO BRIDGE BEING
DEDICATED AND OFF
TO THE LEFT IS THE GUY WHO BUILT
THE BRIDGE, THE ARCHITECT.
DONALD TRUMP SAW NOBODY PAID
ATTENTION TO THE MAN WHO BUILT
THE BRIDGE.
HE SAID TO HIMSELF AT THAT POINT
IN TIME I'M NOT GOING TO BE A
SUCKER.
LIKE THAT GUY WAS.
HE IS LITERALLY DECLARING TO THE
PRESS THIS IS THE MOMENT WHEN I
DECIDED I'M GOING TO BE AN
ASSHOLE.
>> Larry: ASSHOLE OF THE WORLD.